I got my own [__]
Um, speaking of my own [__] I said ask me in 30 days,
but I'm the Hold on. Let me I always have to check and see what's
like been publicly filed or not. Okay, for a Where are we at?
They filed so much [__] incorrectly and this the
docket ends up getting spammed like [__] crazy. So,
what was the last thing that I read on here? It would have been
their It would have been in support of their preliminary injunction.
Would it be plaintiff's reply in support of motion? Would it
be this here? Why doesn't it say how many pages this is? Did
the judge not sanction them? The judge hasn't like done much
yet. The judge has only intervened in our case or had a hearing
for one thing and that was for the temporary restraining order,
which they were rightfully um chastised for cuz everything about
it was stupid. Can you explain to people that say it's unreasonable
for you to request the legal identity of the person because you
most likely know who it is anyway? Yeah, we're going to get to
that cuz I'm going to start to I'm going to make some allegations
here cuz all of this I don't think people realize how absolutely
[__] ridiculous all of this [__] is.
But I don't know if it's being driven by like a lawyer who should
be sanctioned or if the other like plaintiff is actually like
encouraging like illegal behavior or what. I'm not sure, but
whatever. Okay, hold on. Let me download some of these. Buy these
documents that I have in my email inbox. Yes. Usually when you
file some of these things like you have like a 10page limit and
they filed so they filed to have like an extension or an increase
on the page limit because they had so much important stuff to
say when they were filing their support for their preliminary
injunction and all of it was just all like the random crazy [__]
that they say. Hold on. What was this? Was it this one? Plus
a minute evidentary objections. The declaration is dependent.
Okay. Declaration. Was it this? Hold on. I guess I can show this
because it's all public anyway. How do you feel about every single
one of your friends besides Dan dishing you out on something
so [__] [__] Listen, it's online [__]
What are you going to do? It's okay though. You find out who
the real ones are. You find out who the real the real brothers
are. Okay, not this. And I think this is what we I think we just
filed this yesterday.
Um, wait, where's the notice submitting amended circuit? Wrong
event. Wrong event. Wrong event. Nice. Okay. If you win the case,
what would be the consequences for her, which you have to reimburse
some of your legal fees? Um, I don't know. We'll see. Where is
the I'm just trying to find the where's it like their 20page
filing for the preliminary injunction. Oh, was this plaintiff
reply and support a motion? Okay. Yes. Federal court system.
Have my money. Yes, I will support the government. No, it's not
this. This is the motion for the increase in page limit. Okay.
This is the response. This is a long one. No, this is not it.
Holy [__] Filed by this is me. Am I [__]
[__] Hold on. I am. Okay. What did you lick me? Response
and No, no, it's not. I'm not looking for our response. I'm looking
for Okay, this is ours. Okay. Okay. This is our big reply to
their preliminary injunction request. The preliminary injunction
that they're seeking is ridiculous because they're trying to
enjoin me from behavior that they have no proof that I'm engaged
in. I'm not even really being accused of being engaged in it
kind of and everybody knows that I'm not engaged in it. So, like
the big things that they're looking to enjoin are things like
um the current distribution of this video on certain websites
that I have no control over, but they're trying to join me from
doing it. So, it's [__] [__] We had our
big response to that and then they filed another response to
that. I read this one on stream. I'm basically I'm looking for
the last thing I read on stream. Support. Okay. Is it? Okay.
[__] it. Let's just Thank you. Jesus [__]
Christ. Okay. This was their Okay, this was their big meme. Okay,
so one thing to keep in mind is the Okay, I'm restating some
things that we've known. There are four causes of action listed
on the initial complaint. You have the federal one that has to
do with they're cardi claims. What does this stand for? [__]
me, whatever. It's the federal statute that has to do with um
sending material from one person to another uh without consent
of the person to transmit the material. Nothing to do with revenge
porn or recording. It's just like a transmission basically to
an individual as well. It doesn't have to be published anywhere
publicly. But it's a transmission from one person to another
basically when the person who was involved in making the video
didn't want that video to be transmitted to another party to
a third party. So the big issue with the big issue the main issue
with their case is that the the the main issue with their case
is that they are the only like evidence that they have of any
of this uh the transmission of this video taking place to that
rose person were before this law actually came into effect. which
would mean that in the United States of America, laws don't take
effect retroactively. Generally, unless there's like a special
carve out in a congressional statute or in some city, you know,
passing a law, you can't sue people for things that weren't illegal
at the time they did them. Generally
um so regardless of the factual matter of whether or not anybody
was okay with anything being sent, um before even getting to
that, you would say that this case doesn't have a leg to stand
on because you have there's no evidence that that actually happened
when the alleged activity was illegal. So that was one of the
things we called out in our response to their preliminary injunction.
Basically saying like, hey, the complaint is a fatal flaw. This
federal statute that you're suing under wasn't even in effect.
So this this whole case is meritless. And if the federal claim
gets shot down, the other three claims are state claims, meaning
that the whole case would be dismissed from federal court and
then they would have to refile with the other three claims in
state court. I would say I'm confident that they wouldn't refile
this because the other three claims require like a lot more like
malicious intent and stuff and it's they're stupid. They shouldn't
even be on this in the first place, but whatever. I don't think
they would refile, but honestly, these people might the [__]
knows. But those become like unwinable. Like I would almost represent
myself in those except I'm not that arrogant, but they're they're
like really stupid claims. So, one of the frustrating things
that they've done, so in the complaint, there's two things that
they did that were a little bit annoying to me. The first thing
they did was they misrepresented a conversation between me and
that Rose person by having the dates flipped to try to bring
it in statute range. Some people say it's because some screenshots
were posted in European time zone, so the month and the day were
flipped. I would argue that it's probably up to your due diligence
to figure that out before you file a [__] lawsuit.
Um because it was very easy to figure that out, but they didn't.
So whatever. So that was one issue. And then the second issue
is the um plaintiff brings up in the complaint. The plaintiff
brings up that a supporter messaged her and said that the supporter's
sister had been in contact with me and had received the video
in the complaint that's the subject of the complaint two months
ago, which I I have no idea what that's in reference to. I that's
it's impossible, but I'm like, okay, I don't know. It's interesting
that you would include that. One thing that I get very frustrated
about is there's a lot of like some people are pointing out that
like oh Destiny has good lawyers and they have bad lawyers and
that's why you know his side is performing better. That's not
true. The issue so far has nothing to do with good lawyers versus
bad lawyers. Has to do with like bad or bad I would say bad faith
arguments or explicit lying or abuse of the court system versus
a side that is not trying to lie or abuse the court system. So,
for instance, when they filed this complaint initially, there's
absolutely no reason why they shouldn't have have had all of
their affidavit or all of their declarations in line. That's
very easy to have done prior to filing this complaint. Sometimes,
sorry, sometimes you can make the argument that like the publicity
of a lawsuit or something like that maybe would open up maybe
something before even discovery where somebody else would want
to jump in and file an affidavit or declaration, whatever, maybe.
But all of those arguments are completely destroyed due to the
fact that plaintiff decided to make a huge substack post publicly
beforehand to maximize the amount of attention that this entire
ordeal would get. And she already said in her complaint that
there was a message from a supporter who said that their sister
had received something. Okay, so they already had all this despite
the fact that they laid this out on the complaint. So there's
two huge issues that I have. Okay, one is that one issue is that
they made a bunch of claims in the complaint that they didn't
attach any evidence for um like light evidence. I'm not saying
you have to like prove any, but they're like there are no declarations.
There were no affidavit. There were no nothing. And then two,
they want to talk about or bring in so much stuff that's not
a part of this complaint. Nothing having to do with any other
person is relevant to the complaint that plaintiff has filed
against me. Despite the fact that, and I don't want to bring
up names or anything, um, because some people obviously are have
a lot of issues or whatever going on, but if you know anything,
you figured it out. But like there's at least one person who's
tweeted like several times like, "I don't know why my name keeps
getting brought up in this complaint. I'm not a part of this
case. I don't know why they keep bringing my stuff up here. I'm
not a part of this. But plaintiff is for whatever reason just
likes to keep adding a bunch of other [__] in here,
which is not part of the complaint. You're not supposed to do
you're not supposed to do that because it's just it's extra [__]
Especially given the fact that they especially given the fact
that like plaintiff literally asked for an extension on the page
limit here so that they could file a 20page support of their
motion here as opposed to the normal 10 page just so they can
conclude a bunch of other stupid [__] Okay. So, sorry
I'm now I'm venting. So before I was kind of like just kind of
covering this objectively, reading it, giving my perspective
objectively. Okay, now I'm complaining about what I at this point
I feel like this is just bad behavior. Okay, so a few bad behaviors
is they keep bringing up Okay, warning for children listening.
Okay, careful. They keep bringing up evidence over and over again
that is not supporting the thing that they keep alleging. Okay,
Destiny, is it normal for court documents to be written so passive
aggressively? The other videos from his seemingly vast it's no.
It's amateur-ish, especially when you don't have the evidence
to back it up. So they keep referring to some things. So for
instance, that Hannah girl that tried to bait me on Discord into
making statements, I guess, that she immediately posted to just
school's Discord server. They keep citing this as examples of
like, oh, he's still offering to send uh, you know, the video
between him and Pixie to other people. If you read Hannah's own
affidavit, I'm very explicitly and specifically referring to
videos of me performing oral sex on women. None of these have
to do with anything related to any video with Pixie. And they
didn't actually have to do with anything related to the Kiwi
Farms videos either. that there was that was totally unrelated.
We've I think we've responded now I think in two or three different
motions about that but they keep they keep bringing this up over
and over and over again. I don't know why they have never responded
to it. That declaration from that person doesn't further that
but they just keep bringing it up which is very very [__]
annoying. They're also very eager to say like, "Well, hold on."
Sometimes uh defense is bringing up stuff that's not relevant
exactly to the case, even though even though they keep bringing
up insanely random stupid things. Like here, they say that Bonell
is taking advantage of this form to intentionally cause plaintiff
further humiliation by publishing her private sexual information,
saying that me mentioning the fact that plaintiff was the one
who suggested making videos and she eagerly wanted to and all
that, that that was like improper, that I shouldn't have said
that. And then in their next claim here, they say that uh I don't
know why Steven is implying that we said 15 witnesses came forward
to say that they'd received videos of Pixie. We were just saying
that 15 people um told Pixie that Vinyl had randomly shared videos
with them that weren't related to her. Then why the [__]
is that being brought up in this complaint? That has nothing
to do with any of this, right? Why? But whatever. Okay, I've
kind of I've gone over all of this kind of I feel like uh opposing
council is is acting in insanely bad faith. Wait, I said that
it's no bad faith. We'll get to the insanely bad faith [__]
One of the annoying things that they did. Do you have avenues
to complain to the judge? We'll get to that. Ask me that in 10
minutes. Okay. One of the very annoying things about this, aside
from the fact that they keep ignoring aside from the fact that
they keep ignoring over and over again like all of my responses
to everything. Wait.
Sorry. Okay. It's not related to any of this. Wait. At Destiny,
would it not have been best to do a joint suit with you against
Kiwi Farms? If you were actually concerned with holding any of
the like the more disgusting parties involved with this accountable
for like actual revenge porn or whatever, then absolutely a joint
suit would have been much stronger. It could have been a mass
tort. It could have been a class action. There would have been
way more resources dedicated to it. the chances of getting the
feds interested in it would have been way higher. The pressure
on the other parties, I don't even know if Kiwi Farms would be
a called out party here. I don't feel like way strongly about
that claim, but against the actual person who did all of the
public publishing, absolutely. Like civily and criminally, it
could have been much stronger. But that's all [__]
completely now [__] in the [__] Okay.
[__] What was I just saying? Okay, that's not important
right now. What was I just saying? Oh, but that person probably
doesn't have a [__] ton of money, so Okay. Okay.
I remember now. So, one of the complaints that I brought up before
related to um related to that the big 20page [__]
that they filed um oh my god, [__] me. Is that so
they know that their complaint has a fatal flaw, meaning one
of the ele they haven't met any or they're missing one of the
elements to the federal statute. Remember, an element is a necessary
part of a thing. Okay, they're missing one of the elements of
that statute. meaning that none of the behavior that they allege
happened were even in date range of the statute. And if that's
the case and that element is gone, that means that that cause
of action is gone, which means that the court lacks subject matter
jurisdiction to hear the case, which means the case gets dismissed.
In a response to our response to their request for preliminary
motion or preliminary injunction, they bring on another magical
declarant. I won't say her name because they tried to file it
redacted, but I believe in the redacted filing, they called this
person Abby MC.
Um, so who knows who that is, I guess. Okay, there are a few
annoying problems with this filing. Hold on. I'm trying to see
what is public on here. Oh yes, please God. No, stop. There's
a little disjointed now, but I'll tie it all together for you
at the end for what I am pretty sure I understand what's happening.
Destiny, is it not worth it just cuz you can't pay? I don't know
how it works if you can't pay penalty summons. Well, it's not
worth it because it's just it's so much more of a cluster [__]
Like it would be a very it would be a very strong looking case
if you had five or six plaintiffs that were altogether in either
a mass tort or a class action against a singular defendant who
was alleged to have done and you would go on the men's rhea here.
You would say like an actual like revenge porn like publication
who could still do the same thing over and over again. By the
way, that would be a very strong civil case. That would be an
unlosable civil case. Uh, and it would almost certainly, well,
I shouldn't say almost certainly, but it would have very strong
legs to get carried by the FBI as well in a submission to the
DOJ because now you've got multiple plaintiffs. You could do,
you know, discovery and work during a civil case and everything
like it would just it would have a lot of legs to stand on. Okay,
hold on. Okay, so this was the declaration that was submitted.
Okay, so Okay, few things. All right, one first issue. No, no,
wait. I'll get to this. Hold on. Let me read through this first.
Okay. Opposing council is incredibly obstinate and combative.
All right, generally litigants will hate each other, right? It's
civil court, you're suing somebody. Okay, you're upset. Opposing
council should be their lawyers. They don't have a personal stake
in it. You know, they do phone calls. They try to represent their
clients best, but they're not like actually, you know, angry
or obsessed with each other. I don't think that's been the case
here. Okay. I think we filed yesterday a statement in response
to as part of their 11th hour submission to try to save their
preliminary junction and the entire case. They bring in they
bring in this other person whose name is redacted. Okay. When
you redact somebody's name or when you file something under seal,
okay, just to be clear, that filing is protected from the public.
It's so that the public can't see it. You can't hide [__]
from the defendant. Okay? You, it doesn't work. I don't even
know why I have to say this because it's so obvious. You can't
have anonymous and random witnesses or accusers come forward
and not reveal that person and throw them on to cases at the
11th hour to to claim that they're willing to testify, whatever,
without the other person even knowing who it is to be able to
defend themselves. Like, it's [__] [__]
And I would call it a procedural violation, but it's also like
it's more than that. Like it's I don't know if it's sanctionable
behavior, but it's like what the [__] is happening
right now? So we filed a response. Okay. In connection with her
motion for preliminary injunction, plaintiff moves. So moving
means that you're filing something with the court. A motion movement
motion. Lol. Plaintiff moves to file under seal three anonymous
declarations. Plaintiff's motion should be denied for three reasons.
one plaintiff failed to meet and confer prior to filing her motions.
Okay, so again, I don't know how it's shown in TV shows, but
like you don't typically just file something with the court and
the other party's like, "Oh, [__] We got to read
the f. What are they talking about? Oh shit." You have meet and
confers beforehand. Remember, the court is here as kind of like
a mediator, especially pre-trial, to kind of like help both sides
file stuff and get everything on the record. You should be having
meet and confers in between filings to figure out like, well,
what are you guys going to file? Okay, well, this is probably
going to be response and then we'll have this on the record.
You're not just supposed to be randomly throwing [__]
into the docket to to see what happens. All right. So, one, plaintiff
failed to meet and confer prior to filing her motion. So, that
means that they filed something. They filed a redacted filing
without us even knowing who the person is. And then two, plaintiff
refuses to identify the names of the declarance to defendant
Binell's council. Okay, we'll get to that. And then three, the
federal rule and statute upon which plaintiff relies are not
applicable here. At 7:59 p.m. EDT on Friday, plaintiffs council
emailed the undersign stating. Pursuant to local rule 7.1 subsection
A3, we are meeting and conferring on the following motions. Motion
to file under seal certain documents and its proposed order.
Motion for leave to exceed page limit on reply memorandum um
because they wanted to file an extra long uh insane reply instead
of just a normal 10 pages. The documents to be filed under seal
are certain statements by witnesses which purpose is to keep
their names out of the public. You and your client will know
their identities because you have to. Duh. I apologize for not
reaching out before. It's been an intense week. What are you
doing so much with your time that Why are you taking this case
on if you don't have the time or resources for it? They already
used this excuse to be 6 weeks late in filing for their TTRO
which the judge excoriated them for. It was stale. It was kicked
like for no other reason just because I don't even know if she
analyzed much of the merits of it. It was just stale. It was
6 weeks old. How are you filing a temporary restraint order 6
weeks after your complaint? But whatever. Okay. So at 11:40 p.m.
EDT on May 2nd. Okay. 11:40 p.m. EDT. So four hours, no. Yes.
So four hours later. Okay. Plaintiff filed her motion for leave
to file declarations under seal. And then 25 minutes later, uh
EDT on Saturday, May 3rd, after the deadline to file a reply
papers, plaintiff filed the declarations in redacted form. At
10:00 a.m. on May 3rd, Bonell's council requested unredacted
copies of plaintiff's filings. Despite repeated requests, plaintiff
refused to reveal to Bonell the names of her declarance. While
this opposition is directed to plaintiff's motion to file under
seal, Bal also opposes plaintiff's belated request to exceed
PA's limitations for its reply brief. Plaintiff failed to meet
and confer prior to filing her motion and unilaterally certified
those purported efforts. Plaintiff did not carefully edit her
reply papers prior to filing. They're repetitive, wordy, improperly
formatted and contained a myriad of extraneous and irrelevant
information. The court should constrain plaintiff to the 10-page
limit that they didn't need to file. And if we would have had
to meet and confer before, we probably wouldn't have okayed.
I would imagine we would have fought on this motion to exceed
page limit because it's they didn't need 20 pages to say a bunch
of like [__] [__] Okay. Um Okay. The
local rules require a filer filing a redacted exhibit to contemporaneously
serve a version of the exhibit upon all council that is either
unredacted or that contains only those redactions authorized
in connection with producing a document to another party in discovery.
Today, plaintiff has not complied. Instead, plaintiff argues
that because she elected to file redacted declarations under
local rule 53 subsection B1, she is somehow excused from the
requirements of subsection F of the local rule and contends that
Bell has no right to receive the unredacted documents at this
time. Plaintiff provides no support for this contention. At a
minimum, Binell should be permitted to know the identities of
the purported witnesses who are providing testimony against him.
Further plaintiff's reliance on rule 26 C1 of the federal rules
of civil procedure and 15 USC 6851 is entirely misplaced as those
authorities have no bearing on her motion to file under seal
rule 26 pertains to seeking a protective order in connection
with discovery. Um this another federal civil procedure the code
section provides that the court may grant injunctive relief maintaining
the confidentiality of a plaintiff using a pseudonym. Neither
is applicable here. A witness or somebody else is not a plaintiff
like and also like yeah no this is stupid. um for the forgoing
reasons bon request the court deny plaintiff's motion to file
under seal and order plaintiff to file unredacted versions of
the declarations or strike them from the record. Okay, so here
are the emails um back and forth. So this is from um their lawyer
on May 2nd. Good evening. We are having a lot of trouble uploading
some of the exhibits. We tried for a couple of hours without
success with some of them. Attached is the full set of exhibits
to plaintiffs um Jane do declaration that will be eventually
uploaded. We apologize for inconvenience and we'll try to solve
the issue over the weekend or as soon as we get some guidance
from Pacer. Thank you. And then obviously my lawyer says, "Can
you please provide us with he now unfortunately we do have a
typo here. I will be getting reimbursed for this email. They
better not have charged me for sending it." He says, "Unreacted
copies." He means unredacted copies. Okay. So my lawyer says,
"Please provide us with unredacted copies of your filings immediately."
So to be clear, we should have these before they're filed with
the [__] court, right? How are you filing? Well,
I'll get more. And then this this lady responds, "Upon the ruling
of the court on our motion to file the unredacted exhibits under
seal, we will proceed to file the unredacted versions with the
court, at which point you can access them. I would appreciate
a response to my email dated April 28th, 2025 regarding the Discord
subpoena." Okay. Excuse me. What? You don't get to file anonymous
claims that you've unilaterally redacted with the court to make
publicly available to to support other motions that you filed
and then if the court rejects your motion to seal, you can just
strike those and I have no idea, you never make available to
me who any of the people are. That's insane. You can't like if
this was the way that court worked, I could basically just say,
"Oh, by the way, I have 10 people and all of them are jumping
on board saying that you're um that you're uh the plaintiff is
a murderer, by the way. All 10 of them are jumping on. All of
their names are redacted. Uh but don't worry, I filed with the
court to to ask to to file these under seal, which also I don't
even know why that would matter because when you file under seal,
I still get those names. You still make those available to me.
The filing under steel just protects them publicly, right? But
imagine you doing this and then the court says, "Well, no, we're
not going to agree to that." And you're like, "Okay, well, in
that case, then I take them back. Especially when this is the
only person, by the way, that keeps the entire complaint alive.
This is the only because the the whoever AbbyMC is in the declaration.
We don't know who that person is, but whoever that person is
is the only person that keeps this entire complaint alive, right?
So, obviously, my uh lawyer responded and he said, "Without the
court ruling on your motion to seal, you filed redacted declarations.
Please send me the unredacted versions." In his belated meet
and confer email to me, your co-consil representative, the documents
to be filed under seal are certain statements by witnesses which
purpose is to keep their names out of the public. You and your
client will know their identities. We do not. Please provide
that information. Thank you. His response was, to be clear, because
of your client's statement related to Jane Doe and any potential
witnesses, we had to file these under seal. Once the court rules
on the motion, we will proceed accordingly. If the court grants
the motion, you will know their identities. Thank you. This is
not allowed. You're not allowed to do this. Number one. Number
two, this is more irrelevant statements. They try to bring up
like, "Oh my god, he made these statements about who was it?"
Like Justicle and Quean. These people have nothing to do with
this case. They're not part of this complaint. They're not declarants.
They haven't signed affidavit. I don't even know if they're called
out in any part of this. You can't just bring on random statements
and say like, "Well, now because of that, we're going to break
federal rules of civil procedure and just do wild unhinged shit."
It's like you can't just file stuff with the court without making
any of it known to me. And then if the court says we're not going to
file this and just and just just unfile it. You can't do that.
Um and so so um this might be a little sarcastic or snarky. And
if the court doesn't grant your motion, their identities remain
anonymous. Um and then they don't respond. And then council and
then so my lawyer says again, despite our repeated requests,
you have failed and or refused to provide us with unredacted
copies of the declarations. since you improperly filed with your
reply papers on Friday. Your continued failure and our refusal
to provide the requested documents violates local rule 5.4 if
you not immediately provide us with the unredacted filings. We
will so advise the court and seek appropriate remedies including
but not limited to striking the pleadings relying on the unauthorized
declarations and the imposition of judicial sanctions against
you and your client. All rights reserved. Sincerely and then
their reply. Mr. Bretler, note that local rule 5.4b1 4 B1 provides
in relevant part quote if prior to the issuance of a ruling on
the motion to file under seal. The moving party elects or is
required to publicly file a pleading motion memorandum or other
document that attaches or reveals the content of the proposed
sealed material. Then the moving party must redact from the public
filing all content that is the subject of the motion to file
under seal. So I don't know if redacting all content means just
what you want redacted or means everything that that person is
alleging. I don't actually know the ruler. I tried to read the
underlying rule but I I couldn't interpret what that meant. However,
again, this doesn't mean that you're allowed to not make it available
to me. This just means that you might be able to preemptively
file something and redact it publicly with the court, but this
doesn't mean you can keep it from opposing counsel from the defense.
You it's like a fundamental rule in in US legal system that you're
you know allowed to be confronted with your accusers because
remember we're in the discovery phase now. Who am I even supposed
to request discovery on if I don't even know the names of the
people that are supposed, you know, witnesses or people that
are supporting plaintiff's claims?
Um, but plaintiff elected to attach the declarations to the reply
and file a simultaneous motion to file under seal. Defendant
has no right to receive the unredacted documents at this time.
Excuse me, what? It would also be highly negligent if we were
to provide to your client the unredacted documents without the
protection of their identities by the court in light of your
client's public statements over the weekend maligning these declarants.
So no, that's not how any of this works. You don't get to just
have random people jump onto a case, mask their identities, not
provide us with copies of who any of these people are, especially
when these other people are making public statements, which they
have because one of these people allegedly, supposedly, possibly
jumped on another [__] stream to talk a little bit
about [__] So, what the [__] Your client
has also threatened physical harm to other individuals that have
spoken out against him in support of the plaintiff. None of this
has anything to do with any of this case for agreement. I tell
them I could. I tr their [__] house to do I do not
want somebody or I do want someone to kill Driscoll though or
lab or Mr. or
equ you do say okay well I think that the I think defense is
is trying to murder all of the witness or whatever file that
with the court file it with the court have a judge rule on it
file a motion for it and then have a hearing on it you can't
just unilaterally decide I'm going to uh I'm going to just start
having anonymous witnesses come forward and then file it see
if the court accepts it if they don't I'll just like strike it
from the record moreover you have the full unredactive unredacted
substantive content of the declarations. The only redacted portions
are those that would reveal the identities of these declarants.
There could be no legitimate urgency for you or your client to
know these witnesses legal identities. That does not alter the
facts or your ability to defend your client in these proceedings.
So, first of all, you don't get to make that decision. Number
one. Number two, you don't get to make that decision unilaterally.
Okay? Number three, you don't know like if maybe me having access
to that person's name helps me at some point in discovery when
I'm allowed to make requests. Who am I even making a document
request to? Who am I even making interrogatory requests to or
demand to for admissions to? If I don't even know the actual
names of the people involved here, who's to say that I'm in contact
or have contact with any of them? You you can't do this. Okay,
this is ridiculous. All right, for these and other additional
reasons, we will not be providing the unredacted documents unless
they are under seal. What is you don't get to make that decision
or if you want to wait, then you can wait, but you can't file
them first without us having copies of them. We consider our
meet and confer efforts to have been exhausted. What at Destiny?
I think he said he'd only submit things if it was the case that
he could remain anonymous. I heard Jess say that on the stream
last night. So, here's a stronger statement I will make. I thought
about saving these, but I don't even know. I'm honestly so over
all this [__] I think there's a lot of very bad behavior
going on behind the scenes related to this. I already have all
of uh Jessica's contact info and I've already served two opposing
council uh discovery requests related to him and I know a lot
about conversations that have happened and if I don't get copies
of all of those uh that will be relevant to all of these proceedings
going forward. Um and that's true for several people involved
that either think they're clever or cute or don't know that I'm
aware that other people are involved in this. But here is so
here is my really annoying thing related to this. Okay, this
person, whoever screen name ABMC is, that's making this um claim
about getting a uh getting the video that's the the relevant
subject matter of the complaint from me. I think that this is
all a lie. I think that all of this is perjury. And my conspiratorial
thinking is the reason why these were filed redacted was to keep
the name of the person out of direct hands of us so that the
person could perjure themselves without accountability. That's
what my feeling is. Um, we're going through the discovery process
right now and I'm complying complying legally with all my obligations
that I'm supposed to meet for everything else. But I think that
I feel like this person was brought in to perjure themselves
on a declaration in order to keep the case alive with the hopes
that they can somehow scrge up or find something else in discovery,
which they won't. And it is incredibly [__] frustrating
that I'm having to waste more time, more money, potentially draw
this out depending on how long they're willing to lie all the
way to trial because this person is making declarations, but
why are there no exhibits attached? If you're literally claiming
here that you have uh screenshots with conversations with other
people or you have screenshots of conversations, why why is that
not attached anywhere? You could file an under seal if you want,
but that's incredibly [__] weird. Um yeah, so that's
this is really really really really really [__] annoying.
Um, yeah. In docket 65 paragraph 3, they argue they try to confer
before filing, but it's a [__] joke. You should show
that. Um, wait, where? In docket 56 or docket 65 paragraph 3.
Stop. What's the logic behind them doing this? The I think the
fantasy is that they're going to find something else or in in
my nightmare scenario, I guess. Um, but I guess it's not really
it's not a real complaint for me because I guess I'm not a victim
or men can't be victims. So, um I don't think these are technically
private. One of the things that their council brings up in the
email to Andrew is that we haven't replied to their request to
comply with uh Discord subpoena. So, opposing council is trying
to subpoena me, okay, on Discord and Instagram for every single
video and picture that has been sent to or received from or has
been sent by or received from my account for 5 years. I would
rather kill myself than give these disgusting [__]
every That's an insane that is an insane [__] request
in the context of everything that this case is about. Jesus Christ.
Um but that that was the Discord subpoena that they replied to.
We're absing with that. What an what an unbelievably broad and
disgusting request to make of you. But like Jesus [__]
Christ. Um yeah, this everything about this case is just like
so [__] gross. Okay, sorry. You said docket 65 paragraph
3. Although plaintiff's attempts to confer with opposing council
was not made until almost 8:00 p.m. on Friday, May 2nd due to
time constraints, the request would have been received by defendants
lead council, Mr. Andrew Breler at 5:00 p.m. his time, California
doc. Wait, what? Although plaintiff's attempts to confirm with
the opposing council was not made until 8:00 p.m. on Friday,
the request would have been received by defendants lead council
at 5:00 p.m. his time, California. Okay. Doc 44 was not filed
until 10:49 EST. So, they made a request to meet and confer at
5:00 p.m., okay, California time. And then less than 3 hours
later, they filed. Jesus Christ. Keep reading. Um, sorry. Mr.
Brley was made aware of our filing deadline, but did not respond.
Due to this, we notified the court that we provide an update
to our meet and confer efforts. As of now, council for def I
haven't actually read the filing. Sorry. As of now, council for
defendants have not provided any response to our request for
a meet and confer regarding the excess pages regarding act 48.
Plaintiff's motion requests leaves um for the declarations of
three witnesses to be filed under seal in order to protect their
identities. These three declarations were made in support of
plaintiff reply. The opposition someone else filed plated to
attach redacted versions of these three declarations to reply
brief. The portions of the declarations that are redacted are
only those that would serve to identify the witnesses. The substantive
content is not redacted. What does this mean? You can't you can't
have anonymous accusers coming forward. What? You can't do that.
What is this? Like you know everything about the accusers. They
just are anonymous. That's not how this works in court. On Saturday,
May 3rd, 2025, defendants council um what would this be the next
day? Yeah. Mr. Breler responded to the meet and confer request
regarding our request to leave or for leave uh the file responded
to the meet and confer request regarding our request for leave
the file the three declarations under seal to I think there's
a time by demanding that the underside council immediately provide
him with unredacted versions of the three declarations. As of
now, various communications have been exchanged, but no consensus
has been reached. The undersigned council has communicated to
Mr. Breler that pursuant to local rule 54 B1, he will receive
the unredacted versions of the declarations after the court approves
of the motion at docket 48 and their file under seal. These declarations
contain highly sensitive, private, and confidential information
regarding the non-conensual speech or sexually exposed materials
and related communications involving the witnesses. Excuse me.
None of that is the subject of this case. None of this is relevant
to this case, plaintiffs, and other individuals. These witnesses
only agree to bri their testimony if their identities can be
kept private under the direction of the court. Okay, this makes
more I didn't read this before. This makes more sense now. Oh
my god, I just had a [__] brain blast. Some people
have been communicating with me privately that um should I actually
I don't give a [__] now. They shouldn't be talking
to me privately and you should be communicating only through
your lawyer. And the fact that they've been communicating with
me privately seems to imply to me that there is a heavy amount
of pressure with opposing council to elicit what I would say
are obviously false statements in order to keep this case alive.
And I think that is unfucking believable. I think I think I look
forward to showing up next court filing. It feels to me like
opposing council is in over their heads. Don't work in this area
of law at all. This Joan Peters person is a something kind of
some kind of immigration lawyer from Puerto Rico. And this other
guy, I guess, is just uh I don't even know what law he does for
everything. Maybe car accidents. I don't know. Um but they're
in way over their head. Uh there's way too much involved here.
They don't know basic rules of of civil procedure, which I understand
is probably your hardest law school class. I don't know, maybe
go back and and and take a refresher on it. Um, and I think they're
at a point now to where I I legitimately, it feels like it feels
like what they're doing is they are grabbing random people to
perjure themselves, but they're telling the people, "We'll keep
your identity anonymous so everything will be okay because some
of these people have expressed a great deal of stress and frustration.
And it feels like the stress and frustration has to do with the
fact that they are um they're worried because they didn't know
that they would ever be identifiable because they are lying in
some of their declarations. Maybe that's just what it looks like.
For all the reasons more fully set forth and plaintiff's motion,
it is critical to protect the identities of these declarants.
Then file a motion with the court and ask for it. You can't just
throw this on and decide this unilaterally on your own. The honor
sign council has also explained to Mr. Bretley, the defendant
has the full unredacted substantive content of the declarations.
The only redacted portions are those that would reveal the identities
of these. Who am I serving discovery notices to? Who am I asking
for uh information or documents from? who like also if you bring
these people in at the last minute. We don't even have a chance
to reply to stuff that they're declaring in in in um in their
moving for a preliminary injunction there could be no legitimate
urgency for a defendant to know these witnesses legal identities.
That information does not alter the substantive facts or council's
ability to defend his client in the proceedings. Excuse me. When
these witnesses are alleging that I've sent them some kind of
material, how can I even know the answer to this question without
me knowing who the people are that are making allegations? Excuse
me. what or council's ability to defend his client in these proceedings.
As of now, despite repeated efforts, the parties have an unwanted
resolve uh the issue. Accordingly, plaintiff's updated certificate
of conferral is set forth below as follows. Another thing that
these guys haven't responded to that I think we've raised this
issue two or three times. Um they keep claiming that I've engaged
in the deletion of evidence and the spolation of evidence, which
by the way, I think is one of their motivating factors for getting
people to tell lies about messages I've sent them because I do
back up all of my messages. I do have archives of everything
that I've deleted and I can see exactly the messages that some
of the declarants claim to exist that I know for a fact do not
exist on the exact dates in the exact times that we were communicating
with each other. And I don't know if they think that I am just
lying when I say that. But keep in mind that plaintiff has accused
me of deleting evidence over and over and over again despite
never requesting a single document from me ever, despite never
requesting any of this evidence from me ever and despite not
seeking any of the proper explation remedies ever. Um, and also
they haven't responded to the fact that if you are telling me
that I've engaged in expoiation because I'm deleting messages
on Discord, why don't you account for the messages that your
plaintiff has deleted on Discord? Because they have and they've
gone back and edited stuff on January 20th, 2 days before serving
me with a preservation of evidence request, which I would say
is a clear demonstration of bad faith. And if they can't provide
me with copies of the conversation from their perspective beforehand,
then I have no idea how the [__] you could accuse
me of bullion when your client is literally doing that anyway.
Okay, but sorry. Um, there's like so much paperwork and everything
in the background for stuff that I have to respond to, stuff
that I have to reply to. It's these huge lists of like demands
for um, uh, admissions and if I if I don't, then I have to say
why I don't or whatever and like all of these interogatories.
Um, it's just so much. That's what I've been doing in my free
time at night or in the morning. It's just a lot of [__]
that type plus all the money on the legal representation, all
this. But this is um this is incredibly [__] annoying
to me because for whatever reason, even if I felt agrieved in
the beginning of all this cuz I think that the start of all this
was stupid, you know, whatever the [__] it is very
[__] annoying that I feel like now they're engaging
in what I feel is sanctionable behavior. But what the [__]
do I know? Um like this just feels disgusting and gross and stupid
to me. But anyway, there you go. She's actually editing messages.
Um I might even have that in a public filing somewhere. But yes,
um I think I attached a link of an example of a message that
was uh that was edited three months earlier. I think it was a
message in November that was edited on January 20th because you
can see it shows you in Discord when the message was edited.
So it was the day they decided to file that lawsuit or the day
they decided to file me a notice to put me on notice for a lawsuit
that um they began editing messages in their Discord. So, but
do you have the money to keep the lawyers all the way through?
I will spend every single scent I have keeping my lawyers. I
will never ever I'm never settling anything out like this ever.
Um, it's expensive and it's annoying. Uh, but I mean, I guess
I complained before that I'm wealthy and I have nothing else
to spend my money on, so why not on on good representation? Um,
[__] it. How much is this whole legal thing sitting
your back? Um, I think I've paid I think around 140,000 at this
point. So, you know, it's like crashing four new cars into a
into a wall. And I'm glad I'm glad that I can support the local
economy of California. I'm glad that I can support, okay, struggling
lawyers everywhere that I can that I can send whatever they need.
At a certain point, the judge reacts to their behavior. I'm looking
forward to the magistrate judge going over the preliminary injunction
filings and then until then, I don't know what they actually
respond to. But the Destiny lawyers rock, by the way. Yeah, they're
good. They're good at what they do. Um, but this this case in
my opinion hasn't come down to like having incredibly skilled
lawyers that are navigating it in a very like creating an awesome
novel legal theory to navigate the case. It's more just like
filing on time, filing correctly, understanding basic rules of
civil procedure and being responsive to and making good questions
the other side. Whereas the other side and in my opinion at this
point is engaging in in sanctionable behavior I would say or
legal behavior I guess but whatever. Anyway, why not fundra for
the legal fees? Um, I feel like I make too much money to do fundraisers.
Just watch my kick. That's my fundraising. Can't you sue for
the legal fees since this is clearly in bad fa I mean, I would
hope that if they if enough of this behavior continues to pile
up that I can do um that I can ask I don't know if it would be
like anti-Slap or something, but that maybe I would be able to
recover some of that, but who knows? Isn't there some professional
duty for a lawyer to say this type of case outside my area of
expertise like I would expect to see? Yes, but my feeling is
I'm pretty sure there are. I'm especially considering how aggressive
and stubborn and um I would say malicious opposing council is.
I feel like there are personal relationships
um at play here. That's what the feeling is. But how much research
you do on lawyers before you decided on the ones you chose?
Um so I I did a lot of research on and then I got a really good
recommendation for an aggressive law firm that was supposed that
was helping me do the case against the actual leaker guy up in
New York. And then when um Pixie decided to threaten the case
and then follow the case against me, I asked them, "Okay, well,
you guys obviously are on the um plaintiff side of this, who
are the best defendants, who do you think does really well on
the other side?" And um this is a really well-connected New York
law firm. They recommended um Andrew and that law firm in California,
who's been exemplary so far. They've been really good. Um I have
zero complaints. So yeah, but they're they're just very expensive,
but it's going to cost you millions, Destiny, even if you get
to summary judgment. Um, I think that um I seriously doubt I'd
be looking at north of if it ended up going all the way to [__]
trial, which would be so obnoxious. My guess is maybe 750k would
be my the cap on all the spending on this, which would be a pretty
gross amount of um money, but the goal is still to get to it
should be gone in summary judgement. Um because the the plaintiff
has no case. they unless they are willing I mean I don't want
to give them I guess the legal illegal strategy to just get somebody
to blatantly [__] lie all the way to trial and say
no I am going to lie but how does payment work for this do you
pay them per each time they have to do something or bulk at the
end every month I think generally law firms usually initially
you will pay a retainer um the retainer will be the something
they'll bill against and then after the retainer's exhausted
depending on your relationship or how reliable they think you
are they'll just bill you monthly for cumulatively all your all
the services or whatever so how does this work if this goes to
trial can and the people giving them affidavit just refuse to
testify. No, the whole point of an affidavit is that you're saying
that you're willing to testify in the case, right? That's the
whole point of of filing these things. So, has your lawyer been
shocked at how the other council is acting? Maybe. Yeah. But
also, I generally don't want to say anything about my conversation
with my lawyer because that's privilege information. Privilege
meaning it can't be used in any way, such, shape, or form any
of the trials. So, if I mention anything about my personal conversations
with him, uh it would probably be after the trial. Okay, this
is like the only time I will do this. Okay, the only reason I'm
just covering this is so that there's some perspective of mine
out there because there are so much other bad coverage of this.
Um, I have spies everywhere. Okay, so I see Jessica and their
Discord is all in cope mode right now, obviously. So, he's spamming
in all caps. This is only about my one instance of sexual misconduct.
Examples of me engaging in this exact kind of sexual uh misconduct
during the exact same time period, victimizing the same group
of people, including the plaintiff, are not relevant uh correct
in a civil suit. If you want to have multiple allegations against
a person, those people have to join the civil suit as plaintiffs.
You can do it in a class action where you certify a class of
people or you can do it in the form of a mass tort where a bunch
of people come forward and make the same claim with different
representation. But yes, welcome to the real world. It's not
a Discord chat and it's not a Reddit chat and it's not a forum.
If you want to have people join a suit, they have to officially
join it. You can't just randomly put in uh Redditor arguments
in every [__] filing and say, "What about that and
that?" Because those issues haven't been litigated. They haven't
been litigated. They're not before the court. They're presumptuous
of of my character and other stuff. Like that's not anybody else's
business to decide on right now. Like um yeah, so it's inappropriate.
It's improper unless other people want to formally join the lawsuit.
But okay. Anyway, would things be different? Meaning plaintiff
would have a much stronger case if the alleged um actions happened
after the day that law went into effect? Um potentially. I mean,
well, at the very least, the lawsuit would have legs so they
could sue. The issue is that in my opinion and this would be
I guess partially for a jury to decide um obviously the internet
has their opinion but the issue is that what they want to do
is they want to invoke all of the damages that plaintiff has
suffered as a result of not my action but another party's actions
and the other party's actions is making this published on a website
like Kiwi Farms but that other party isn't named anywhere in
the lawsuit. So to hold me accountable for all of those damages
would be incredibly challenging. Um you're dipping into concepts
in legality called proximate harm or foreseeability. So what
you would have to argue is and you would have to do this very
cleverly and very carefully. You would have to try to argue that
me sending the video to another person, it should have been foreseeable
that that video would leak to somebody would leak to the to the
public at large. But that would be incredibly difficult because
one, you would have to claim that it was foreseeable for me but
not foreseeable for plaintiff. Number one, and then number two,
you would have to claim that it was foreseeable and I did it
knowing that I would be immensely harmed as well, which is incredibly
weird. Um, and then you would have to argue the approximate harm
is mostly on me despite the fact that the atlarge publishing
of the internet was done by another party. It's just even if
the even if they had that and even if they were to theoretically
win or get like um you wouldn't call it a conviction, a favorable
ruling saying, "Okay, well we think that this statute was broken.
We do hold the um defendant accountable." When it comes to calculating
damages there, there's going to be a big question of like, okay,
well, which damages do we calculate? And that gets very complicated
because like I said, I'm not I haven't published any of this
publicly anywhere. You haven't brought up any of the parties
that have published it anywhere. and plaintiff made a huge tactical
mistake of exploding the lawsuit prior to actually filing anything.
They didn't file an anonymous lawsuit under a Jane Doe under
a protective order where they could have filed the entire thing
under seal which would have kept their damages claim much stronger
because obviously if it were to go to court one of my counter
retorts is going to be and I have all the views for the videos
over time. Hey look, this video had 5,000 views after plaintiffs
made their substack. This video has 60,000 views. um how can
you assign damages to me when the person publicizing this so
much is incurring their own they're essentially increasing the
damage to themsel and if you look at all of the underlying case
law it's a new law right it's 2023 I think is when it became
active or end of 2022 it's a new law so there's not much case
law on it but if you go through and you read these cases you're
not going to find any example ever of plaintiffs publicizing
their own leaked material prior to taking any of the defendants
to court but whatever you know what do I know I'm [__]
[__] I guess anyway
Okay. Jesus. So, can you summarize the stuff happening with Justical?
Are you going to sue him? Uh, they're a Canadian person, so I
don't even know. Number one. Um, number two, um, we'll see what
happens. I've already put in a discovery request related to him,
but he was talking about this on his stream yesterday and he
I feel like my feeling is that he knows that there is tom foolery
about because I think he said on stream I think he said that
he was not going to join this unless he had guarantees or assurances
that all of his stuff would be kept redacted and anonymous which
makes me feel like he also knows that there's improper stuff
going on here. So we lose the lawsuit. Do you consider a convicted
felon? No, this is civil stuff. He would just lose a lawsuit.
What are you restricted from doing while the case is going on?
Nothing. Well, I mean, it's hard to work with people publicly.
Although, I guess I'm talking to more people. Apparently, they
don't care that much. But does this firsthand exposure to legal
system make you appreciate the justice system or be frustrated
by it? Um, I mean, I appreciate I'm frustrated by opposing council's
behavior, but I feel like they're um I mean, they're just acting
insanely. So, okay. Anyway, will you be able to make a statement
on exactly what you've done wrong after the case, or is there
a good chance that it will be dismissed due in competence? Everyone
still calls you a rapist after it? Um, I don't know. That's a
personal decision that I'm going to have to decide for myself
because um right now there are a ton one there is an incredive
there is an incredibly aggressive and I think personally invested
opposing litigation firm that is like hanging off of every single
public word that I say like it wouldn't surprise me if aspects
of this um if this conversation will show up in the next [__]
filing. Right? So they are doing um they're doing uh they're
they're just incredibly aggressive. Uh, number one. And then
number two, uh, it feels like they're like desperately searching
for other plaintiffs. So, I don't know if somebody else is going
to try to file a case against me using the same law firm or or
whatever the [__] else. So, I Yeah, I don't know.
We We'll see. I don't know. We'll see how I feel after everything,
but Jesus Christ. How often do you speak to your lawyers? Are
available? They're very available. I speak to them as little
as possible because you get charged for conversations. If it
cost you 140K, how much do you think this is costing her? She
only raised 50K so far. So, one complaint that I would have about
how the court system works
um is that I feel like in a way some of this bad behavior is
a little bit incentivized. I think that opposing council, the
feeling I'm getting that it feels the feeling that is being admitted
is that they are working on a contingency basis, meaning they
only get paid if if the if plaintiff gets paid. So, they're also
incentivized in the same bad behavior because they're basically
working on um commission kind of. So that might also be influencing
their behavior. That feels like a very weird conflict of interest
to me, but whatever. Do we have a timeline on when they would
next meet with the judge? No, that's what I kind of keep pushing
for questions about. The next thing will just be this ruling
on the um preliminary injunction, but apparently there's not
necessarily a timeline on that. So, you know what that cryptic
uh Pixie tweet was? Uh or no, I have no idea. I doubt it's anything
related to me. It's probably I mean I can guess, but probably
something related to YouTube or there some project she wants
to work on or whatever. Why would Pixie need to raise money if
the case was on contingency? Good question. Since people are
saying [__] publicly and going on streams, at what
point has become okay to start just leaking [__]
Um, I mean, you can leak whatever you want. You're you're always
fine to leak whatever you want. The the the only disadvantage
there are disadvantages and there are advantages to leaking or
talking about some stuff publicly. It's just up to you to evaluate
what you want. The biggest disadvantage to leaking stuff is that
when you're having a conversation with your um with your lawyer,
that stuff is considered privileged information, meaning it can't
be used against you ever or probed uh in court. So, like, let's
say that I'm talking to um let's say that I'm talking to my council,
okay? And let's say that I'm being accused by one side of stealing
$100,000 from their house. And let's say that and and they're
saying like, "I know that you stole $100,000
um because uh because Luke said that you just bought a new car
with cash, so I bet you stole it or whatever, some [__]
like this." Let's say that I'm talking to my lawyer. I'm like,
"Okay, fuck." One thing that I'm really nervous about, and I
don't think um I don't think the plaintiff even knows this. I
was actually at their house on the day that they said that the
cash got stolen. So, I'm kind of nervous about that, right? But
let's say that they they never figure that out or they don't
know that or nobody alleges that. That's fine. But they can't
um subpoena or they can't on discovery say, "I want to know everything
you've said to your lawyer." And then your lawyer says, "Well,
just so you know, my client told me he was at your house on the
day the money was stolen." You're like, "Oh, [__]
Now I'm fucked." Right? Because obviously if that was the case,
then you could never confer with your lawyer because your lawyer
is really just supposed to be an extension of yourself, right?
So the the big one of the big reasons why you wouldn't want to
leak anything is because you're losing some of your attorney
client privilege if you do leak that stuff. Um, and then there
could be other reasons too or not depending on the case. It just
depends. Are these complaints or opinions about the procedural
behavior backed up by your lawyer or just based on your knowledge?
Um, both. I usually have an inkling and then I ask my lawyer
about it and he more or less affirms but but it's also obvious
based on the filings and it's obvious based on the contention
and it's obvious based on the um on what the judge was saying
listening to the TTRO request that the other side is acting quite
improperly. So okay I think last question somebody earlier said
why did she follow through with a lawsuit when she could have
had you help her with her personal expenses like school and [__]
Surely any lawyer worth their salt would say yeah just do that.
The issue is that the amount of money that she wanted was at
least one or two orders of magnitude higher than anything I would
have ever there's no world where there is a seven figure payout.
Even if I lose the case, even if the jury [__] hates
me. Like there's no world where that is ever the payout. So,
one, the request for the payout was way too high. Number one.
Number two, in my opinion, now there's not like a civil cause
for action for any of this, and I don't know if any of this rises
to any kind of whatever afterwards. I I would say very obviously
I think that um plaintiff who was extorting me or blackmailing
me. Um I think that all the elements of that crime are very easily
and very clearly met. Uh they were trying to compel me to engage
in a behavior that I wouldn't have engaged in otherwise by threat
of publishing some sort of private information that would have
been humiliating or detrimental. And the in exchange for keeping
that private, there's a huge sum of money requested or some other
thing compelled that you would normally do. Uh because plaintiff
contacted me prior to ever contracting a law firm or anything.
I think is very easily it meets all the elements of extortion
or blackmail. Extortion I think or maybe it's blackmail I don't
remember one of I don't even know the difference one of those
two but but all the elements I feel like are easily there. Um
uh and so okay and then also I think that the I think that maybe
they think so one I think that she probably got gassed up from
people saying like oh no like he's rich and people win millions
and millions of dollars from these lawsuits all the time so I
bet you know you'll get millions and millions of dollars. The
problem though, again, and I'll say this, if you follow any of
these cases or if you read any of the case or if you just read
the cases that they site, um, if you go on Pacer and you look
up the cases that they site, sometimes there are big payouts,
but dude, the defendants in these suits are insane. They're insane
men. They're people who are like spamming explicit videos to
their like friends and family or they're making like six different
accounts to post these videos like on, you know, porn website.
They're insane defendants. So the so sometimes just even on some
of these crazy cases it's just like the max statutory payout
which is 150k and then sometimes there's punitive stuff assessed
but the punitive stuff assessed is like for incredibly malicious
behavior but maybe a combination of like reading kiwi farms and
a combination of reading everything else. Maybe Pixie has in
her mind like oh my god like he acted so atrociously and maliciously
and like I think this is all intentional and was like the [__]
you're never convincing anyone of this and it's just [__]
So I don't know. or and then on the last um the last thing is
maybe in her mind because I'm probably going to end up spending
a lot more on this um than what she could have asked for, maybe
I'll just settle with her because I'm um maybe I'll just settle
because I want to avoid the legal costs. So maybe that was what
she was. But I I would rather I will pay two times more legal
cost than settling something like this because [__]
that. The idea of somebody getting like like the easy next 10
or 20 years on their life by doing some insane unhinged [__]
like this, I'm good on that. But anyway, okay, there you go.
Cut. There you go. Have fun. Uh, Carlos and Joanne or whatever,
uh, listening to this whole VOD because I know how much you guys
love to type [__] up in your motions and throw them
into court papers by listening to my stream combos. How much
you think plaintiff believed the insane lies on her Substack
or still believes. I don't think she believed any of those. I
think she knew all of that was [__] There's no shot
that we're friends for 5 years and then she immediately hardcore
Insta super ultra rewrites every single That's just impossible.
I don't believe that. Do you think that she was genuinely suicidal
or was it an attempt to manipulate you? Um, I mean this is like
double hearsay. I don't um in the video of um in the video that
was posted on was it Professor Sunday? Not professor Sunday.
President Sunday's channel. Oh [__] Wait a second.
Oh wait, hold on. What is there a link to like the thing that
I published? Wait, I just realized something. I despite the fact
that everybody claims otherwise cuz people think I'm legitimately
I guess people really do think or some people I think I don't
know if it's my haters or what think I'm actually insanely [__]
arrogant. I do pass [__] by I pass everything I publish
by my lawyers first. Some people like, I bet he's I bet he's
stupid enough to think that he's smarter than his lawyers and
does like [__] no. I'm not I'm not [__]
[__] Why would I even risk that? A pretty good assessment
of how smart I am. I would never risk anything that stupid. Um
but I just realized I wonder sometimes when I'm referencing things
that I put in a first draft of a statement and not the actual
thing that got published. Now, um where is the um I made a public
I made like a when I did like my minifesto. Did I ever link that
publicly anywhere? Oh, wait. Hold on. Okay, hold on one second.